so a while ago we talked about the
lambda calculus which is a simple but
powerful mathematical theory of
functions but something we didn't talk
about at the time was the idea of
curried functions which sound a bit
spicy but are actually very useful so
that's what we're going to talk about
today curried functions as we often do
we're going to start off with a question
and the question is what actually is a
function so for me a function simply
takes an input on one side processes it
inside and then gives an output on the
right-hand side so you can think of it
as being a little box or a little
machine takes an input on one side
processes it inside the box and then
produces some output on the other side
so let's have a simple example of a
function and as usual I'm going to be
using Haskell but you can basically do
everything I'm going to show you today
in any modern programming language that
provides some support or the lambda
calculus so the example I'm going to
start with is a simple increment
function and we define it like this
increment of X is X plus 1 so just adds
1 to a number so you can kind of have a
look at the anatomy layer so the
structure of this and we're doing three
things we're defining a name for the
function we're calling an Inc for
increment we're defining a name for the
input parameter X and we're explaining
how the output is calculated in terms of
the input so we can have a couple of
examples of this we could increment the
number one and we get two or we could
increment the number two and get 3 so
it's all very simple and all very boring
so let's move on towards curried
functions now and the first step we want
to take is the idea of applying a
function to a function as an input so
let me give you a simple example of this
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
map the increment function that we just
defined over the list from 1 to 10 so
what map is is it's a function which
takes two parameters the first parameter
is another function in this case the
little increment function that we just
defined and the second parameter is a
list of things in this case a list of
numbers from 1 to 10 and what map does
is it takes the function here and
applies it all the way across the list
so we're just simply incrementing and
all the numbers from 1 to 10 and map is
called a higher-order function because
it takes a function
one of its infants so let's have another
example of something a bit more
interesting let's think about the idea
of a function which has more than one
input or more than one parameter so we
could find a little function called add
and we're going to take two numbers X
and Y as inputs and then we're going to
simply add them together an important
point here is that we take the two
numbers X and y packaged up together as
a pair at the same time okay so what
we're going to do then for an example is
we could add one and two and give three
or we could add two and three and give
five so all very simple and again all
very boring as well it's not really
anything anything new at the moment so
what then is a curried function so a
curried function is a function like add
which takes more than one input but
rather than taking them at the same time
packet as a pair or a triple or
something like that it takes its inputs
one at a time so how could we redefine
add as a curried function what's very
simple we just take the brackets out so
rather than saying add of XY is x plus y
in brackets we just say add of X and
then a space and then Y is X plus y so
it looks basically the same except we're
taking the two inputs x and y one at a
time now rather than at the same time in
pair and then we can apply this function
in exactly the same way as before and we
just give it two inputs like one and two
and we get three or we could say what's
two and three and we get five okay so it
looks basically exactly the same as the
regular addition function except rather
than taking a pair of inputs at the same
time it takes two inputs one at a time
so then you can say well what's the
point of defining functions in this
current manner well the point is that
you don't need to give them all of their
inputs so for example if we did add of
one and we see what it says oh we
actually get an error here so why do we
get an error so we get an error because
this is still expecting its second
parameter so if I apply add to a single
number one it doesn't know how to do the
because we haven't given it a second
number and that's what it's saying here
it's trying to print a function here so
it says I don't know how to show a
function from integers to integers or if
you want a more a slightly
comprehensible message it's saying maybe
you haven't applied a function to enough
arguments okay so with a curried
function which takes its input one at a
time you can partially apply it to a
subset of the inputs so what could you
actually do with a function like add one
well we could map it for example so here
is a way of incrementing a list of
numbers without defining a custom
increment function so previously we
defined Inc of X as X plus 1 and then we
mapped it here we're using the add
function which is curried because it
takes its inputs one at the time and all
we're doing is giving the add function
one parameter here and then it's a
function which expects the second
parameter and then it will map that all
the way across the list so we get the
same behavior using this general-purpose
addition function without having to
define a custom increment function so
you can ask yourself at this point
what's actually going on with a curried
function when I say it takes this input
one at a time what does that actually
mean so let's kind of look at this
definition again so here's the
definition we had out of XY is X plus y
what we can do is do a simple lambda
calculus trick here rather than having
the two inputs on the left hand side of
the equals let's move them across the
equals sign to the right-hand side of
the definition and we'll do this in two
steps so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say add of X is lambda Y arrow
X plus y so what I've done here is the Y
is no longer on the left-hand side of
the definition here now it's on the
right-hand side of the definition so
what this is saying is if you add a
number X then what you get is a function
which is waiting for a second input Y
and then it's going to give you back X
plus y and this expression on the
right-hand side here is called a lambda
expression it's a nameless function and
it's got the same kind of anatomy as a
normal function definition except for
the fact that you don't give the
function a name so we look at what's
going on here
we're taking an input parameter called Y
and we're
bring back the result X plus y but
nowhere in the blue box here have we
actually given the function a name
it's a nameless function and then we can
actually play the same game with the
other input as well so rather than
having X on the left hand side we can
move it across to the right hand side
and here we have our definition of our
add function in a more primitive way and
this really lets us understand in a
quite fundamental way what's going on
with curried functions what we're saying
is the the addition function is defined
to be the function which takes an input
called X and what you get back is
another function and that function takes
an input called Y and then gives you the
back the result X plus y you can ask
yourself where does this idea of
currying come from well it's named after
Haskell curry who was a mathematician
and logician who studied these kind of
things but Haskell curry himself he
wasn't the person who actually invented
this notation and or this idea he
attributes it to someone else called
Moses shown Finkel who was also a
logician and mathematician working
around the same time showing chling is
quite a hard word to say I've had to
practice it quite a lot even to be able
to say it today it's not it's not a word
which is very easy to say where as
currying kind of just trips off the
tongue it's a nice easy word to say so
curry got the credit for it but really
probably Moses Schon Finkel is the one
who first studied this idea so just to
wrap things up I want to give you an
example which shows that actually
curried functions are quite natural in
the real world as well not just in
computer science so if you think about a
cash machine what does a cash machine do
well it takes three inputs typically you
put your card in you put your PIN number
in and you put a request in and then
it's going to give you some response
which usually is taking some money out
and let's make this a generous cash
machine let's decide that it's always
just going to give you a hundred pounds
or a hundred dollars right but this is
not actually how cash machines work when
you go up to a cash machine you don't
put all of the three inputs in at
exactly the same time well maybe on the
Saturday night when you've been out you
try and put all the three inputs at the
same time but this is not what happens
in practice I mean you put your card in
then you put your PIN number in then you
put your request in and finally the
machine is going to give you some money
out and that's because it's really a
curried function so let me redefine it
like
that so here we're defining it as a
curried function it takes its inputs one
at a time so we take a card then a PIN
number then a request actually we can
use along the notation to make this even
more clear what's going on what we do is
we take a card and we get back a
function it takes a PIN number and then
we're going to take a request and then
we're going to give back our 100 times
so for me this definition down in the
bottom here really captures the essence
of what a cash machine is as our curried
function so it's a function that takes
your card as an input and what it gives
you back is a function that expects your
PIN number and that function takes your
PIN number as an input and then what you
get back is a function that takes two
requests and finally when you get the
request the machine will be very
generous and just give us our hundred
pounds or your hundred dollars so that's
really all I want to say today about
curried functions they're a very simple
idea it's functions with multiple inputs
that you define in a way that the inputs
come one at a time rather than all
together and as I said at the start they
sound a bit spicy but they're actually
very simple and very useful functional
programming languages take care of a lot
of the implementation details that in
older programming languages you have to
do manually for example memory
management but nowadays it's very
popular to use languages like even Java
for example which builds memory
management into the programming language
functional languages do that too